so I'm working on you know managing my
Wine Library TV Facebook page what to do
some interaction I noticed wine Hotel
Pinot Noir account left a message that
says this week's winery hotel data
information 10% discount book online and
left an email
why do brands in any shape before but
I've been seeing this happen a couple of
times and I'm sorry to pick you out wine
Hotel Pinot but timing is everything in
life sorry uh why don't prance think
it's a good idea to come on other fan
pages within their genre and spam the
wall I you know I haven't wrap my head
around it it's not that effective for
everyone random lucky conversion you get
you're losing twenty conversion
potentials long-term and the people that
hold these accounts like me that could
conceivably Biss death with somebody
like this completely completely are put
in a place where they're disgusted at
best and they will never do business
with you so I don't know I've been
seeing a lot of people more and more go
to face book pages and leave you know
offers or deals or trying to use it to
siphon you know traffic I think it's a
grave mistake and I think people should
think about it because characters like
me will pop out make videos about you
wine Hotel Pinot